hey everyone it's Sarah with registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I'm going
to be reviewing Strider first let's
listen to some audio of what Strider may
sound like
now how do you know that your hearing
Strider well you want to pay attention
to a few things first thing is timing
Strider can be heard on inspiration or
expiration and it's going to have a high
pitch in addition it's going to be
continuous and located mainly in that
upper respiratory system like the
trachea slash throw area and it's going
to have a defining auditory
characteristic that you really can't
ignore it's going to sound like this
screeching squawking noise that's coming
mainly from that throat area so again
let's listen to this audio of Strider
foreign
so what causes this sound well it's
occurring because there's narrowing of
the larynx and the trachea from swelling
due to some type of infection or
blockage from an object and it can
actually progress where that Airway will
be completely blocked off therefore some
cases of Strider are life-threatening
and require immediate attention so it
depends on the severity of the Strider
how severe does it sound and what is
actually causing it now Strider can be
caused by cases of epiglottitis or croup
where you may hear it referred to as a
barking cough in the Pediatric
population it can also be caused in
cases of anaphylaxis or if there is an
object stuck in this throat region okay
so that wraps up this review on Strider
and if you'd like to watch more videos
in this respiratory series you can
access the link in the YouTube
description below